[Music]
Lisa Marie Presley's ex-husband Nicholas
Cage speaks out following the news of
her sudden death
Lisa Marie died on Thursday after
suffering a cardiac arrest at her home
in Calabasas and on Friday her third
husband Nicholas Cage released a
statement to E.T calling the news
devastating quote Lisa had the greatest
laugh of anyone I ever met she lit up
every room and I am heartbroken the
actor added that he finds Solace
believing that she is reunited with her
son Benjamin Keough who died by suicide
in 2020 at the age of 27. Lisa Marie is
also Mom to 33 year old Riley Keough and
14 year old twin daughters Harper and
Finley I don't know it they I just I'm
like that um if I really I love I love
them to death so I can't anybody that
hurts them anything happening with them
I feel if they're sick I get sick if
there's something happens to them I'm
going through it you know it's it's
really a
beautiful but painful situation Lisa and
Nick met at a party in 2000 and married
in 2002 but their marriage was a
short-lived Whirlwind and Nick filed for
divorce just two months later we're the
same in terms of being really really
dramatic and dynamic I think
individually we were pretty capable of
being that way and together it's just a
force that it's either amazing or it's
not it's so intense that it's not going
to ever just be mediocre it's never
going to be something you know nice and
sort of quiet
following their split Lisa Marie told
E.T they were still friends and said
Nick was a fan of her music from what I
gathered he liked it a lot I mean he
there were some songs that I wrote that
I wasn't going to put on the record that
he really liked and that because he had
such a heavy response to them I put them
on the album
[Music]
Nick was Lisa's third husband she first
got married to Daniel Keo and later
Michael Jackson
if you just reach out for me girl
and four years after she split from Nick
Lisa Marie married a fourth time in
2006. she said I do with Michael
Lockwood well he can handle so many
things I worry about him and he's really
calm he takes care of everything I've
just never seen anyone like him the two
welcomed twin daughters in 2008 but by
2016 Lisa Marie filed for divorce
following news of her death Michael's
attorney told E.T he is focused on their
children and adds that Michael had been
hoping for a speedy and complete
recovery and is very sad it didn't turn
out that way quote Michael's world has
been turned on its ear
foreign
[Music]